foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
happy Thursday everybody so some
breaking news the Supreme Court has
ruled that race-based affirmative action
programs are unconstitutional it's been
around for 45 years and I guess one of
the justices finally read the
constitution for the first time
yesterday and was like whoa
true it's been a while since the Supreme
Court treated the Constitution as
anything but a paper towel for when
Biden spills is unsure
and the reason for the change is also
the reason for tonight's monologue it's
been over 150 years since America banned
slavery but here's an interesting fact
that Folks at Reuters just dug up I love
Reuters a lot of powerful people in the
U.S including our living presidents
Supreme Court Justices Governors and
legislators descended from slave owners
that includes Republicans Mitch
McConnell
I'd say he took one on the chin but we
all know that's not possible
foreign
but also Lindsey Graham James Lankford
and Tom cotton cotton his name sort of
gave that away
if he ever ran for president he should
not use the the slogan pick cotton
not gonna work a cities
[Laughter]
[Applause]
I'm sorry I would not advise that either
yeah all right
and if those old white men didn't
surprise you how about Dems Tammy
Duckworth Gene Shaheen Maggie Hassan and
Liz Warhead right that's got to be tough
for those women of color right Liz
Warren must be asking how how
is this possible
but the fun part every living president
is a descendant of slave owners
well except one and can you guess which
President is free of that ancestral
shame no not that one his ancestors own
slaves and pointed reparations just get
awkward
and no definitely not this one his
ancestors owned slaves too though to be
fair Joe was just a child at the time
so who's the exception
[Music]
[Applause]
it's true
djt is the only one whose ancestors
never owned slaves although he was rude
to some of his apprentices I'll give him
that
and he's the guy the media had dub the
biggest racist in the history of racists
right does it matter now will it matter
to Reuters or they wouldn't have done
all that research they wouldn't have
thrown rocks at all those family trees
hoping to dislodge some of that sweet
and juicy race bait the media craves it
the way hungry bears crave a beehive
full of Honey or the way Brian stelter
craves a beehive full of honey
so why is this a bigger deal you know
that Trump's ancestors are clean it
seems newsworthy I mean remember during
the 2012 Presidential election there was
a big news story about Rick Perry's
hunting ranch it had a rock with a
racial slur painted on it which his
family painted over in the 80s Perry had
nothing to do with it the sin was
committed before he was even born yet
somehow the media treated it as evidence
that he was a racist but then every
Republican running for office is accused
of racism even if they're not white
merely belonging to the party that freed
the slaves is evidence that you want to
bring back slavery according to the
freakish media that's why they can call
Larry Elder a white supremacist instead
of giving credit for who he really is a
powerful spokesman for Relief Factor
of course when you point out that the
Democrat Party was the party of slavery
and past Jim Crow laws that kept the
South so segregated you'd think it was
Martha's Vineyard
they'll tell you that today is
Democratic party is way different now
cool then why can't the rest of America
use that same defense
because clearly they're different from
that era as well except it never works
out that way does it why doesn't Trump
get any credit here I mean the worst
thing his family ever bought and sold
were buildings not one human ever if
slavery is a foundational evil if we're
all expected to repent for sins that
were committed Generations before we
were born why doesn't that guy get any
extra credit you don't have to like
Trump or even think you should be
re-elected but you got to admit it's
pretty weird that all those journalists
did all that work to dig up so many
facts about powerful Americans and they
only mention Trump's Clean Hands in
passing I guess it's just a coincidence
that the party of slavery and the people
who vote for that party try to paint the
one guy who sat in the White House who
has no connection to slavery as the
worst bigot ever and when facts don't
fit that assumption it's just best to
move on so the media claims to want to
remind us of our history except when
that history actually reflects well on
somebody they decided is the face of
evil as reuter puts it quote
establishing the Grim team details of
the history of slavery is essential to
understanding the nation's past and
bridging racial divides what is it or is
it just digging up ancient history to
divide Americans even more
by the way does this now make Trump
exempt from reparations I mean he truly
is the least racist president in history
the irony of that is thicker than my
file in HR
what
tonight's guest she's a political Maven
who gives a left no say Dave in 2024 GOP
president candidate Nikki Haley
the only fire this pyro starts is in my
heart co-host of fox and friends first
Todd Pyro
she never gets up on the wrong side of
the bed because she sleeps in caves Fox
News contributor captive
and for his July 4th barbecue he's
grilling an entire Ruth's Chris my
massive sidekick in the NWA World
Heavyweight Champion Tyrus
Governor Haley thank you for returning
to the show we usually don't get returns
people usually do it once and then they
say that's it never again it's great to
be back oh thank you thank you you truly
are a politician what do you make of the
Supreme Court decision
you know I'll tell you when my son was
putting in college applications he's
like Mom dad's white you're Indian I'm
screwed right I mean that was the way he
looked at it and what I'll tell you is
look I was born in a small rural town in
South Carolina
and we were the only Indian family I
became the first female minority
governor in the country when I became
governor of South Carolina I went on to
be un Ambassador I'm now running for
president this is the best country in
the world we should be telling our kids
it doesn't matter what your background
is if you work hard you can be anything
you want to be and that's what we need
to be talking about
I don't believe that I don't think
that's true I could definitely not play
volleyball no you can't I've seen you
you have no athletic ability no it's
actually astounding it is it's
disgusting let's let's move on the image
is is horrible uh Tyrus welcome back
good to see you yeah just stepped off
the plane yeah and then the plane just
went like this
you get it parking big and I stepped off
yeah they got it it just sucked
so isn't it funny that remember what
Trump used to say he was the least
racist president ever oh apparently he
has that he has the genetic proof
you know it's funny because they said
you know we all come from slave owners
some of us come a little close than
others yeah it's my light-skinnedness
thank you uh so it's not sensitive at
all the thing is about look scary white
people I love it just laugh it's fine
I'm light-skinned okay
a lot of mixing and whatnot back then
still goes on today even in this country
pyro just ran out of the building yeah I
know
his parents are here so he can't go too
far but it does prove one thing they'll
say it doesn't matter
whether Trump's
ancestors own slaves or not
they're right it doesn't matter just
like it doesn't matter
that old Biden his parents did own great
great parents whatever the hell
ancestors own slaves it doesn't matter
there either right because it doesn't
matter you hear where you are now
because of the effort that you put in or
your family put in going forward so it
really doesn't matter where your roots
are is what your flower looks like so
you know what I'm saying just oh I like
that yeah that was really nice thank you
yeah did you come up with that no okay
cat's texting me but it's true you
shouldn't have to pay for what your
ancestors did I'll be in trouble I mean
this is what upset them yeah because
they got him yeah this whole thing was
another dossier dig where Trump came
from a long long line of slave owners so
after all the weeks and
Clinton fund money they're like
yeah
everyone but him yeah everyone but him
no yes uh I guess print it yeah and
that's right and it sank like a stone
yeah they were like Teddy Kennedy date
hey Todd Hi how are you I'm well and
yourself sir yeah uh I'm okay I'm okay
we did our own research on your ancestry
so your great great grandmother was
Lizzie Borden yes yes uh this is the
first time we've released this
information but I don't think it should
matter that your great great grandmother
was a homicidal maniac she liked axis
yes what do you make of the
this uh Reuters thing couldn't agree
with Tyrus more I mean just because I'm
Italian am I in the mafia you know Are
My People connected to the mafia you
gave me a weird look I just looked for
Captain because I don't think anyone's
ever thought you were in the mafia
this doesn't look like a mafia lawyer
yeah I don't think anyone's sorry I
don't think anyone's ever thought you
came from the mafia never ever thought
that you've known anyone from the mafia
that you've met him from the mafia that
you've been in the same room it's not
good informant though yes you do give
off informant
so last time I was on the show you were
like you give off realtor at a
convention
what was the question what do you
remember what show is this I don't know
it's it's called Gutfeld and it's just
we should change into abusing Todd
um the old the overall point to tyrus's
point none of that matters like I don't
care that Liz Warren is descendant of
slave holders just I don't care that
Donald Trump isn't and I think if I
could go to a I'd hate reading things on
your show but I thought Clarence Thomas
thing really ties all these stories
together today in his concurrence he
said every time the government uses
racial criteria to quote bring the races
together someone gets excluded and the
person excluded suffers an injury solely
because of his or her race I think
that's a common theme between both of
these stories today nothing that is
immutable to me including my ancestry or
my race should determine what I'm
supposed to do and who I am now in the
present that's what the left wants to do
and I think that is what this decision
today tries to undo hopefully we can
move forward as a country going forward
I think we will move forward I think we
have moved forward from slavery yeah we
do you think so yeah I better tell them
I'm pretty confident
as in yeah we don't have it don't you
think that that article by Reuters would
have been a great thing to write about
because it actually is saying the
results are saying exactly what you but
but they didn't choose to go that path
yeah I saw it this was I was like
monologue I was like it's a slavery I
was like okay interesting choice so I I
yeah I my family didn't have slaves I
want to be very sure about that too so I
texted my cousin yeah
and I hate reading things on the show
too
hello I'm sure you're extremely busy
planning your wedding that is in two
days
congratulations Courtney uh but quick
question do you know if our family was
here during slavery she said no um
what does she do for a living she's a
police officer she's detective well if
she's a police officer then I would
trust marrying another police officer
fox loves it right yeah they're like
what are they doing after the wedding
could they do fox and friends
all right quickly before we go in
support of my new book we're doing a
virtual event July 27th at 6 p.m COI
treat Tom backstage at our live shows
and more insane stuff too for more info
go to gutfeld.com hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else